The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality, educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So as you might have
noticed, much of for this
class, and much of our work, in
a sense, is about designing
good policies, given the
particular challenge and
environment--
the policies functioning
in it.
So that's a lot of what we do.
If you look at a lot of how
policies are made in the
world, it has less to do with
the problem then to do with
other priorities.
So the example we give
in the book is
emphasized here, is Egypt.
Egypt became a major recipient
of US aid in 1979, when Egypt
essentially broke ranks with the
Arab countries, and signed
the Camp David accord
with Israel.
And the Camp David accord was
not quite a declaration of
friendship, but it was enough
of a change in the
relationship that Egypt was then
on seen as a major ally
for US/Israeli interest
in the Middle East.
So it was a very substantial
political change.
As a reward, in a sense, for
agreeing to that, Egypt was
offered a lot of
aid every year.
So Egypt the biggest recipient,
other than Israel,
of US aid over this period.
And that was not based on the
idea that either that Egypt
was a country that was
particularly poor--
Egypt is one of the richest
countries in Africa--
or on the idea that Egypt
was going to do a lot of
good with the money.
There's no such presumption, no
such idea was ever mutated.
It was very clear that the money
in Egypt was supposed to
be a payoff for being
friendly--
a payoff not necessarily to the
President, but a payoff to
maybe, to some extent,
to the military
establishment in Egypt.
So a payoff nonetheless.
So it was very much
seen as a payoff.
So as a result, when
basically, if
you take the amount--
enough aid was given to Egypt
every year to pay $20 per
African child under five.
So just to get a magnitude
of that--
Egypt is one of the richest
countries in Africa.
The aid given to Egypt was so
large that if it was given to
the rest of Africa,
it would be $5 for
every child under five.
So that's a significant
amount of money.
It was not given based on the
idea that Egypt was going to
make very good use
of this money.
And it was not really
development aid.
It was just aid as a price
for being our friends.
And that's an important
example, because it
underscores the point that even
though we may work very
hard, and come up with policies
that make sense,
often money is spent for reasons
which have nothing to
do with sense--
or may have sense, but sense
in some other calculus.
And that's related to a separate
point, which is-- so
one point that comes up in that
process is that, what's
the point of knowing anything
if money will not be given
where the information is?
So the information says that you
should do this policy, but
in fact, Egypt gets all the
money because it happens to be
the country that's willing
to be nice to Israel.
So that's one question.
Related question is some
countries just don't have a
functioning state.
Right now, prominent example
is Cote d'Ivoire.
Cote d'Ivoire, if you noticed,
has an ongoing civil war where
the president is supposed to
have lost the election, but
doesn't seem to want to leave.
And there's a French army in
there, which may or may not
succeed in re-establishing
order, et cetera.
So at this point, we might
discover a very efficient way
to find people will get people
to immunize their children,
but that might be beside the
point in Cote d'Ivoire.
It's true that in Cote d'Ivoire
right now, there is
no state, and therefore, if you
think of a policy that's
going to be adopted by the
state, who's going to do the
state that adopts that?
So a lot of people have
made that point
against us, if you like.
And I think the most articulate
version of that is
this paragraph by Bill
Easterly, who says,
"Randomized controlled trials
are infeasible for many of the
big questions in development,
like the economic-wide effects
of good institutions or good
macroeconomic policies.
Embracing randomized control
trials has led development
researchers to lower their
ambitions." So basically, the
big issues are not being
touched here.
What we are doing is
we're solving--
it's a small problem, and the
implied argument is that if
you don't solve the big
problems, there's no reason to
salve the small ones, that we
should start by solving the
big problems of state
formation, of good
macroeconomic policies,
getting an effective
functioning state, and then
solve the other problems.
So there's a lot of people who
are, I think, are very fine
economists who believe in this
position, which is what I
would call the institutionalist
view.
And really two separate,
possibly independent claims.
One is that without good
politics, you cannot have good
policies; and the second is that
with good politics, good
policies will follow.
So their claims in two
directions, right?
One is a positive claim, the
other's a negative claim.
That is, it's hopeless to
try to do anything if
you have bad politics.
And you here, what people really
mean by politics is not
just that you should have a good
leader or something, but
you need a whole package of
what people think of as
appropriate institutions.
So the basic vision is that the
appropriate institutions--
and the things like
property rights.
Basically, is it private
property or not?
Is private property
well secured?
That's one thing people
focus on.
The second thing people focus
on is whether the political
system is relatively open.
There's some constraints on
the executive, or whether
there is basically absolutism,
so the guy who's running in
power can do whatever
he wants.
So those are the kinds
of things.
So I'm going to keep using
institutions with
capitals for awhile.
And you'll see why later.
So I'm going to use it in
capital for the time being.
So let me say what I'm
trying to get at.
These are not only
institutions--
MIT is an institution, too--
but it's not institution in
the same sense as property
rights is an institution.
I'm sure, it might be as
[? venerable ?], respected
institution, but it would not
count in the same sense as
institutions in this sense.
This is institutions meaning
these big things that define
how the economic and political
system jointly functions.
There are institutional, few
kind of structural features of
the economy, which drive
everything else.
And those are things like
property rights, political
system, et cetera.
So I think one interesting place
to start is to look at
the work of Acemoglu, Johnson,
and Robinson.
Acemoglu and Johnson are
both MIT professors.
This is a really interesting
book.
And what I'm going to try to--
what they claim in their book
is that countries succeed or
fail based on institutions as
defined by property rights--
few things like the nature of
property rights, the nature of
the political system,
et cetera.
And what they have done, I
think, very compellingly is
provide some very interesting
evidence along these lines.
So I'm going to start by
presenting the evidence.
And then, we'll think about
what, given that evidence, how
should we think about
the world?
Now the first reason why this
evidence is difficult is
because institutions
are androgynous.
What do I mean when I say
institutions are androngynous?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
wanted a place that's very
distractive, or had a very
[INAUDIBLE] infrastructure.
It would tend to stay the
[INAUDIBLE] of time.
PROFESSOR: So you're saying that
it's the opposite, saying
that institutions are not
affected by local conditions.
AUDIENCE: Well, they're
initially [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: They are initially
[INAUDIBLE] by something.
But once they're in place.
PROFESSOR: They're formed
by something.
That's the key.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
instituations was created
by [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Do you want
to add to that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I wanted to say that the state
of the society [INAUDIBLE]
determines which institutions
it [INAUDIBLE].
But at the same time, the
institutions contribute to
[INAUDIBLE]
the state of the society.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you might say that, for
example, to have effective
property rights, we need
effective courts.
To have effective courts, we
need effective judges.
To have effective judges,
we need an
effective education system.
To have an effective education
system, we might need good
properties.
So all of these things
are related.
The investment in the education
system may not be
effective without property
rights, so all of these things
are related.
So basically, institutions are
androgynous in the sense that
lots of things that matter for
other aspects of the economy
also affect institutions.
Institutions are a result of
what else is happening in the
economy they also cause.
So that's what makes
it difficult.
So how do you study
the effects?
Problem with things that are
androgynous is that, how do
you study the effects
of those?
Because in some sense, the basic
rule of us studying the
effect of something is what we
want to do is we want to say,
here's two countries.
One country has better
institutions than the other
entirely by chance, not because
this country has some
other aspect that makes
it better, right?
The problem is, we're worried
that if I say that Spain has
better institutions than
Portugal, then I would need to
argue that this is not a result
of the fact that Spain
was, to start with, a stronger
economy, and that's why the
institutions came out.
We want to say there are two
countries essentially
identical, and by an act of
chance, Portugal got worse
institutions than Spain.
And those acts of chance
are difficult to find.
That's basically
the challenge.
So how does anybody solve
this problem?
Well, here's a very
nice insight.
The very nice insight is that
in former colonies--
so take the counties that
were European colonies.
It's a lot of countries--
pretty much all of Africa, and
most of Asia, and most of
Latin America.
All of Latin America, most of
Asia, and most of Africa were
former colonies of either
Britain, France, Holland,
Portugal, Spain, or Belgium.
So essentially, these six
countries were between them--
Germany to a very
small extent--
had most of the world
carved up.
So most countries were colonies
of these countries.
And it turns out, not
surprisingly--
it's what was said a
little while ago--
institutions are persistent.
So if the institutions were good
institutions were set up
in this country a long time
ago, they still remain
relatively good.
And if bad institutions
were set up-- so
good and bad here--
I'm not telling you what would
good and bad are, yet I'll
tell you what they
mean in a minute.
But the basic theory is that
whatever institution was set
up a long time ago, that's
how they stay.
So institutions are
persistent.
That's step one.
Step two is to observe that when
Europeans settled in a
country, they were very clear
about what kinds of
institutions that wanted to set
up, and that has a lot to
do with whether they want to
live in the country or not.
If they didn't want to
live in the country--
so they just wanted to go there,
control the country,
and make some money from it,
then this institution they set
up enabled making money quickly
in the country.
So they were not very protective
of the local
population.
They were what are extractive
institutions--
institutions which basically
take the shape of--
it's easy to kind of bully
people, not a lot of legal
protection, so that you could
extract whatever you wanted.
You want the mines to
be very profitable.
You don't really want legal
rights for the workers,
because if you have legal rights
for the workers, then
they will complain, and then
you wouldn't get very
profitable mines.
So if you want mines to be
profitable, the best way to do
it is to not have very many
legal rights for workers.
If you want labor to be cheap,
you don't want to educate the
labor force.
If you want people to be docile,
you don't want to have
a lot of democracy.
On the other hand, if Europeans
were going to stay
there, then the vision for the
country was very different.
They wanted it to be livable,
and kind of like
their lives in Europe.
And then the set of
institutions, which were much
less directly extractive.
And that happens to be
true, sadly enough.
So what are countries where
Europeans did settle?
And what are countries where
they didn't settle?
Examples.
AUDIENCE: The United States,
Australia, Canada, Argentina,
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Those are
good examples.
What are countries where
they didn't settle?
And you can start to see what
the pattern is going to be.
What are countries where
they didn't settle?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry.
Well, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Where did Africa
get their [INAUDIBLE]?
South Africa.
To some extent, Zimbabwe.
To some extent, Kenya.
Those were three countries where
they settled, and most
other countries, they
didn't settle.
Now one reason--
so here's what's nice
about the paper.
They claim that one reason this
happened was because of
settler mortality.
So if you look at these early
colonies in the first years of
settlement, there are massive
mortality rates.
Really massive, like four out
of five people died within
five years.
That kind of mortality rates.
Because Europeans were
encountering new diseases,
basically--
new tropical diseases of all
kinds-- so the mortality rates
were massive.
And so therefore, the places
where they did agreed to
settle were places where the
mortality rates were
relatively low.
And so one good predictor of
what happens whether you get
one good predictor, or whether
you get a European settlement
or not, is settler mortality
in the early days.
And so, what they did, which is
very creative, is to find a
data set of settler mortality
in these places.
So basically, the idea is, let's
look at what happens.
Let's compare places where the
settlers died in droves with
places where they didn't.
So here's a set of pictures
that underpin their paper.
So let's start with
the first one.
This is the picture of GDP per
capita on expropriation risk.
Expropriation risk is how
secure are property.
So expropriation is the opposite
of property rights.
So expropriation risk is just
how likely is it that if you
have a private property,
it will just be
taken away by the state.
And you see that countries
where it varies a lot is
Haiti, in Mali, in
Niger, Nigeria.
It's low in the US, Singapore,
Australia, New Zealand.
So if you look at the colonies
that do well, they tend to be
relatively--
the richer colonies are also
the ones which had lower
expropriation risks.
Now this is androgynous
regression, because you could
have almost shown
this regressions
the other way around.
You could have asked, is it the
case that rich countries
have lower expropriation
risks?
This is not a regression that
can be causally interpreted by
itself, because it's exactly
saying that expropriation risk
is high in these countries.
But is that because rich
countries are safer, or is it
because safe countries
are richer?
We don't know.
Now before I come to a-- well,
actually, let me skip these
two pictures, come back
to them later.
Here's a more maybe
revealing picture.
So this picture says, what's
the relationship between
settler mortality and
GDP per capita?
Now this is kind of a dramatic
fact, which is that if settler
mortality was high, like in
the Gambia, GMB, Nigeria,
Mali, Togo--
those countries are poor.
Countries which are rich
tended to have
had low settler mortality.
So if we think that settler
mortality has nothing to do
with GDP today, then that's
a surprising fact.
Why was it that settlers, when
they came to settle-- when did
they come to settle
in the Americas?
When were the Americas
settled?
16th and 17th century.
When was Africa settled?
19th century.
So these are all
the long time.
When was Asia settled?
When was Asia conquered?
18th and 19th, mostly.
Everything that we are talking
about is saying that, what
happened before 1850 or 1880,
basically, has a strong
consequence on outcomes today.
So if were in a country where
Europeans died in droves in
1870, like in Gambia or--
I don't know, whenever
that was, 1860--
people died in droves in 1860.
Then Gambia is still
a poorer country.
So that's sort of an interesting
correlation.
And here's why they think--
then ask the question, now that
I told you that Gambia is
poorer than the US, and even
120 years ago I could have
predicted this, you say why?
Why would that be the case?
How could you?
What's the link between
120 years and now?
And their claim is that this
is the persistence of
institutions.
So Gambia is a place where
Europeans didn't settle.
And as a result, they set up
extractive institutions, and
extractive institutions
are very persistent.
So the reason why we see this
mapping from settler mortality
to expropriation risk to GDP is
the reason why we have the
persistence.
Settler mortality affected
institutions when the country
was set up, which affected
institutions now.
And it's very dramatic again.
The quality of institutions
goes down very fast with
settler mortality.
So that's the basic argument.
The basic argument in the paper
is these two facts,
which is that, look, countries
with a high settler mortality
are poorer, and they have
poorer institutions.
And there's no reason why
something that happened so
long ago would affect outcomes
today, and therefore it must
be institutions.
Now, they do something else
that's actually very
interesting.
In fact, they do
more than this.
One thing they do is to argue
that in the world of like,
let's say, 1500 or 1600, we
don't know GDP in 1600.
So what they are going to try
to argue is not just that we
see this pattern, but that this
pattern doesn't reflect
fixed geographical
characteristics of these
countries, because if you
have fixed geographical
characteristics of these
countries, then the countries
where you had low settler
mortality would have been
countries which were richer
already in 1500.
So one thing they wanted to show
is that this is not the
effect of some long-term,
historical difference.
It is not that the countries
that have low settler
mortality were rich
countries already.
So the US, which had low
settler mortality, was
actually a poor country
in 1500.
How do they show that?
Well, they can't actually
measure GDP in 1500 very well.
But one thing they can do is
they can use urbanization
rates, or population density.
Historically, richer countries
had more population.
So let's start with this.
Start with this picture.
This picture says that you look
urbanization and GDP per
capita, these are extremely
correlated, right?
Extremely, tightly correlated.
So then they're making the
point that therefore
urbanization rates in 1500
are a reasonable
proxy for GBP in 1500.
OK, that's the second step
in the argument.
So this picture says
organization rates in 1500--
if you assume that's a predictor
of GDP in 1500, then
look at that relationship.
What does that say?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The richer the
country was in 1500, the
poorer it is now.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I'm not sure I understand
the niche.
Wouldn't initial population
density play a huge role?
So maybe the populated areas
were kind of [INAUDIBLE]
the temperate zones that were
colonized later, and then
settlers set up their
own settlements.
And any one of those [INAUDIBLE]
talked how not
having a population in the first
place was one of the
reasons they settled
there, as well.
And also, if you're looking at
urbanization rates, shouldn't
you care the tropical colonies,
before they were
organized to European countries
that did the
colonization, and you see higher
organization rates in
the temperate zones that
have a [? purple ?]
population densities.
PROFESSOR: OK, those are
both good points.
Hold them.
We'll come back to them, OK?
You're asking questions on
whether this argument is--
you're trying to pick holes
in this argument.
Let's wait on that.
I want to understand the
argument before picking holes
in it
So I think both points you
made are interesting.
But hold them.
We will repeat them
in a minute, OK?
So right now, they're
making the case---
look, it's not that there's
a persistence of poverty.
It is not the case that the
countries that were poor in
1500 are poor now.
If urbanization is a good
measure poverty, of being
wealthy, then those countries
were rich countries then, and
are poor countries now.
And the US, for example, was a
poor country then, and a rich
country now.
Indeed, famously, there's a
claim that the reason why the
British didn't manage to take
back the US in 1776.
The US was very weak, relative
to Britain in 1776.
How did the US colonies
manage?
Well, there was a threat of
another attack to, I think, to
Jamaica, which was a much
wealthier area--
sugar-growing, much
wealthier area.
So that's why the British
government had to decide
whether to protect Jamaica,
or to predict the US.
And it decided that Jamaica
was more worth than
protecting the US.
May have not been the right
judgement historically.
But nonetheless, so they made
this call on it, based
apparently on the fact that
Jamaica was a wealthier area.
This is another one.
This is a [INAUDIBLE] population
density, which is
another classical measure
of wealth.
So typically, historically, more
populated countries have
been richer countries.
Indeed, historically, people
have suggested a very simple
model, which is sometimes called
the Malthusian model,
which is that if countries are
more productive, they can
sustain a bigger population,
because if you're not more
productive, then you have
a bigger population,
you starve to death.
So basically, the Malthusian
model says that more
productive countries had
bigger populations.
And you see that if you believe
that, then once again,
richer countries in 1500 are
poorer countries now.
Finally, population density
in 1500, you can see, is a
negative predictor of
expropriation risks now.
So more dense countries in 1500
was protected against
risk expropriation.
So they had less property
rights.
And what this is saying is that
you look at the economic
outcomes of the higher
urbanization countries and the
lower urbanization countries in
1500, you can see that the
higher urbanization countries
actually fall below the lower
urbanization countries in the
middle of the 19th century.
This is GDP.
So they call this the
reversal of fortune.
So two claims being made.
One is that rich countries
became poorer, and the reason
why they became for poorer is
because of the paternal
settlement, which generated
better institutions, which
generated better economic
outcomes.
Then they go on to claim that
if Zaire had the same
institutions as the US today,
it'd be five times richer.
So that's a huge claim, right?
It's huge.
The magnitudes they're talking
about are immense.
So now coming back
to the question.
You were trying to start asking
questions about this evidence.
What are possible ways in which
this evidence might be
misleading?
So let's go back to you.
AUDIENCE: One was that I
thought maybe they're
dismissing the geography
explanation if you compare
tropical countries before they
were colonized to European
countries before they actually
colonized the other countries,
because it might be in North
America and New Zealand and
Australia, they had better
institutions, didn't really
have populations settled there
in the first place.
It's probably one of the
reasons that European
colonizers set up camp there.
PROFESSOR: So you're saying
empty may be different.
The development patterns may be
different for a variety of
reasons, which may not have
to do with institutions.
It may well be that if you start
with an empty place, you
can have a different development
pattern, even if
you have the same
institutions.
That sort.
One of the things.
Is that you're saying?
AUDIENCE: Kind of, but also
that if you're trying to
totally dismiss that the fact
that climate may have played a
role, you shouldn't compare
places with similar population
densities to start off with.
So you should compare
Europe to--
PROFESSOR: Why would
that make sense?
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Because in comparing
Latin America and Saharan
Africa, one of the papers talked
about how there already
were rich cultures thriving
there, and that it was a
reversal of fortune.
But if you're comparing those
places to, say, North America
and New Zealand, the population
of North America
and New Zealand were small.
There wasn't a lot going on.
So maybe you should compare
it to Europe.
I think Europe would have been
a lot more prosperous if you
compare it to the
Incas, Aztecs.
PROFESSOR: I see.
You're saying that maybe
comparing with the empty place
is misleading, because
those places are--
but still, isn't the point
that this is misleading
because empty places, for some
reason, would have a different
development path.
After all, the empty places
across the [INAUDIBLE]
become better.
So you're saying that even
without good institutions,
empty places might have had a
different path, because maybe
it is the case that just
the population
composition is different.
If there's no one else living
there, and I go and settle,
I'm 100% of the population,
whereas if there's a lot of
people living there, then if I
go settle, I'm a different
fraction of the population.
OK, you were-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you think the
countries that actually
colonized--
the ones who actually
go and settle--
do you think [? depending ?] on
the country, does that make
a difference on how well
the colony does?
For example, all the colonies
that ended up doing well were
British colonies.
And of course, you have
India, which--
PROFESSOR: There's a lot
of British colonies
that didn't do well.
Nigeria, Ghana, Uganda,
Sierra Leone.
Lots of British colonies.
Burma.
AUDIENCE: Right, but most of the
other ones, those happened
at different times, right?
Like many of the--
a lot of the [INAUDIBLE]
happened later on,
and the love of
exploration happened in Africa.
Of course, there was already
traffic in terms of slavery
and things like that.
I'm thinking into 1600 or so.
But a lot of the colonies that
have been in Africa were in a
different time.
[INAUDIBLE] history spectrum.
So I just think that the big
market was just different.
The world was very different
at the time.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but I
don't see why that's
another good point.
I agree with everything
you said--
whoops.
You want to add to that?
I don't understand exactly why
that's a criticism what
they're doing.
I understood if you said--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I was just asking a question
actually, because that's just
something that comes
up when I--
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
absolutely true.
I think everything
you said is true.
But I don't see why.
So they were definitely
colonized in different times,
but still, two things they do.
One is the compare
within Africa.
They can compare
It's not quite statistically
as solid as it should be.
But you can still do it.
You can compare Zimbabwe, South
Africa, Kenya with the
rest of Africa-- the countries
that have high settlement and
low settlement, and you see some
of the same difference.
Mostly different by South
Africa, unfortunately, which
is rather special.
But the second thing you can do
is you can control for the
identity of the colonizer, and
that doesn't change anything.
So you can compare only British
colonies with British
colonies, and that doesn't
change anything.
That's much more solid.
So you could compare just French
colonies with French
colonies, and British colonies
with British
colonies, and average.
AUDIENCE: So even
within Africa--
PROFESSOR: I don't know whether
you can do that
[INAUDIBLE] that becomes
two small a data set.
So if you compare only Spanish
colonies within Africa, there
will be two.
And that's not going
to be a lot.
AUDIENCE: I'm not saying
within Africa.
Would you say that British
colonies are probably better
off then, let's say, Portuguese
colonies where you
have Angola and [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It's probably
true, actually.
AUDIENCE: Whereas you compare
that to South Africa, South
Africa's much better off.
PROFESSOR: It's probably true.
But that's not what they do.
They're worried about--
that comparison is difficult,
because British colonies are
not randomly chosen.
Britain was one of
the leaders.
In African colonization,
Britain
was one of the leaders.
Britain got all of the most
productive countries.
So if you look at--
sorry?
AUDIENCE: What about France?
PROFESSOR: France
was a follower.
And so, France ended up with the
less productive countries.
So Britain targeted some
countries, and then grabbed
the best ones.
So this is not an accident.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So to follow on the
earlier point that emptier
places versus more heavily
populated places that
[INAUDIBLE]
if a place is more populated,
then it already has some kind
of institutions.
And if some institutions already
exist, whether they're
equitable or not equitable, I
think it would be much easier
to establish institutions
would not be equitable,
because the system is
already set up.
PROFESSOR: That's a point,
but that they won't
disagree with, obviously.
Imagine that they said that
places which have no one
there, or very low population
density in the beginning, it
was easier to set up fresh
institutions, and fresh
institutions persists.
Would you say that's not
a version of the
institutionalist argument?
That's just a slight variant
of their argument.
I don't think it's
that different.
AUDIENCE: Well, I don't think
that if it's an empty place,
then the probability that you
could settle and then
procreating an institution
would be lower.
PROFESSOR: That's
absolutely true.
I think they would say that
that's still an argument for
expropriating institutions
are bad.
You're just making a slightly
different argument of why
expropriation institutions
are bad.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, just getting
back to the point [INAUDIBLE].
So when you say, yeah, that's
correct, the British empire
was sort of the leader of
political lines in Africa.
However, that's not the case
when you're talking about the
Americas, right?
Right, so even though Spain and
Portugal were the leaders
in this case, it's not like
they did invite a
colonization.
And when you even referenced the
paper, if British empire
chose the regular countries in
Africa [INAUDIBLE], wouldn't
that imply that they would
have a [INAUDIBLE] more
aspiration-based, and therefore
maybe South Africa
would be in a worse position?
Does that make sense?
Or does it show that--
PROFESSOR: It's not so clear.
They might have chosen-- we're
getting off point.
Let's say just to comment, the
British might have picked
better places, and better
places might be more
productive.
It might also be more
attractive to be
expropriating, but those two
factors are going in opposite
directions.
So if you started with
better places, that
already helps you a lot.
And maybe they knew exploit a
bit more, instead of slavery
or something.
But still, it might well be on
balance that you do less
damage there.
It's not clear, because you
start with a better place,
then you do a little
more damage.
I don't know which
way it goes.
But you're right.
That's a certainly good point.
Any other concerns?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
if you could just [INAUDIBLE]
geographical argument, because
it's [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, to be honest,
I think if you look the world
in 1800s, the United States
doesn't look like a more
valuable economy.
It looks like a less valuable
economy, because the idea was
that places that could
grow sugar were the
most valuable places.
So when you compare places to
the Americas, they typically
compare Jamaica with the US.
And Jamaica was a place which
looked more valuable then.
US was actually a good place to
settle, because no one was
empty, and no one wanted
to come there.
So it was empty, and no,
not much competition.
The British were very
worried that the
Spanish would take Jamaica.
Yeah, keep going.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
America [INAUDIBLE]
South America [INAUDIBLE].
And North America [INAUDIBLE].
I mean, it is or Asia,
[INAUDIBLE]
but it's [INAUDIBLE] in
Africa [INAUDIBLE]
least favorable, in
terms of the land.
[INAUDIBLE]
is a very poor [INAUDIBLE].
The institutions point
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: But that's the point
about the reversal of
fortune, in the sense that the
reversal of fortune is exactly
point that these were
richer places.
In 1500, the places which are
poor now were rich places.
So somehow, you need to argue
that geography has a different
effect then than it does now.
It's not implausible, so one
point you could make is that
geography is not some
fixed thing.
These countries were richer
then, because this was a
period when it turned out that
agriculture mattered.
And then, they invested
a lot in agriculture.
Turned out that by some
accident, industry became the
big thing later, and so places
that started later were more
able to jump on the industry
bandwagon than the places
that-- so geography that helped
you originally might
hurt you later.
Because Jamaica specialized
in sugar.
Sugar was great in 1800, but
not so great now, because
something better
was discovered.
So maybe what happened was that
these places that were--
it was not the institutions.
It was just the specialization
in certain products that
really mattered.
You want to continue?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Africa [INAUDIBLE] more
resources [INAUDIBLE]
just going to pick [INAUDIBLE]
agricultural countries.
PROFESSOR: But in some
sense, why is that--
find.
But isn't that just a version of
the institutional argument,
that where you want to extract
diamonds, you don't create any
institutions, you
just extract?
And that's exactly their point,
in a sense, is that you
create extractive
institutions.
That doesn't seem any
different from--
seems like a variant on the
argument, that where you set
up extractive institutions,
you get bad outcomes.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So could it be the case--
[INAUDIBLE]
because they had invested a lot
in agriculture and that
was the thing back then.
They were well off, and as times
changed, there became
less of an emphasis that other
countries would invest
[INAUDIBLE].
It could also be the case that
other countries, the ones in
temperate environments, were
forced to look at other things
early on because they knew that
agriculture wasn't there
[INAUDIBLE] and that was a bet
they made not knowing how the
future would be [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's an
excellent point.
So it could be that just if you
have very easy access to
the very productive agriculture,
then you'd be in
a society which is not looking
forward to solving certain
types of problems.
So that's an excellent point.
I don't know if it's true or
not, but it's an extremely
interesting observation,
and part of that.
And more generally, one concern
with this kind of
evidence is, that, as you
might imagine, the most
compelling examples turn out
to be Hong Kong, Singapore,
South Africa, plus US, Canada,
New Zealand, Australia.
The regression's driven by very
few countries, though I
think if you look at this
picture, it's less true than
you might imagine.
Yeah, we can do this one.
So we look at this picture.
It's not entirely driven by--
so if we look at that square
in the middle, even there,
there's a slight
downward slope.
So leave out US, New
Zealand, Canada,
Singapore, Hong Kong, Malaysia--
those are on the left--
and just South Africa and
whatever, one other country.
I don't know what it is.
And look at the block in the
middle where India is the top
left-hand point,
and whatever--
MLI is Mali--
is the bottom right point.
Even within this square,
there's clear
downward slope, I think.
So even if you left out the very
rich countries, you do
get a weaker but significant
relationship.
And that still tells you,
if you just took that
relationship, you still will
get a big effect of settler
mortality, even if you left
out the few really
exceptionally rich countries,
or something.
You still get reasonable
good fit.
I guess one concern I have is
whether or not expropriation
risk is something that
we have assign to
countries based on success.
So one worry I have is that it
may well be that the countries
that have high settler
mortality are
poor whatever reason.
And then we think it's because
of expropriation risk, but
expropriation risk is just based
on our perception of
economic success.
So India and Pakistan saw very
different expropriation risk.
One is at eight and the
other is at six.
I'm not sure that those are
based on anything in
particular.
I think there might well be
a legitimation of success.
So countries which
are successful
are assigned better--
with these numbers, who knows
what expropriation risk is.
It's some number somebody
made up.
And we may worry that this
number isn't quite right.
And maybe all it does is it just
reflects the fact that
richer countries are richer.
So people assign them higher--
these countries are richer,
they must have
good property rights.
I don't know how much of
that's what's going on.
But I still think that, in some
sense, I guess I'm more
inclined to take this evidence
as telling us something
interesting.
But I think one should take
it really seriously.
So first point it's making-- if
you take it seriously, it's
not just the institutions
that are important.
It's not saying just that
institutions are important.
It's saying something much
more specific than that.
It's saying that institutions
that were set up a long time
ago, and evolved slowly over
time in countries where there
was low settler mortality
are very different from
institutions that were set up
a long time ago, and evolved
for a long time in high settler
mortality countries.
So it's not saying that if I
suddenly took Mali, and gave
it the institutions of the
US, the institutions will
automatically start
functioning.
That's not in this data.
It's not saying anything about
whether or not we can be
replace institutions in one
place or the other, right?
It's in fact saying quite
the opposite.
It's saying that all we can tell
is that places that good
institutions because of a lucky
accident 200 years ago
or 400 years ago are
better off now.
That's not necessarily
a big helpful policy.
It's not that it says that we
could change institutions
today successfully.
That's not what it implies.
It could be true that we could
change it, but that's not what
we learn from this evidence.
What we learn from this evidence
is if we happen to
have been lucky 400 years ago,
then we are lucky today.
But that's a very different
point from saying that we are
able to fix institutions today,
and if we give Mali the
same institutions the US had.
And I'm not just making
a debating point.
Think about what the US
constitution means.
The US constitution means a
lot of things, but it also
means every school who goes to
school in the US learns about
the constitution.
It creates a certain set of
loyalties to the constitution
that are very important.
It is emphasized that this
constitution has a long history.
there were lots of battles about
this constitution in the
Supreme Court and
other courts.
All of these things are part
of the effectiveness of the
constitution.
It's not just the constitution
that is effective.
The US constitution is given
content by all the judgments
of the Supreme Court.
The famous judgments of the
Supreme Court is what makes
the constitution what
it is today.
So it's not clear that you can
just transplant a constitution
without the history
that goes with it.
So that says that if you believe
this point of view,
you should be very pessimistic,
because it's not
actually saying that we
just have to fake good
institutions.
This is where I think
it still is wrong.
Even if you believe this point
of view, it doesn't say much
about development policy,
because it actually doesn't
tell you that you can fix
institutions today in Mali,
and you'll get good outcomes.
And as Acemoglu and Robinson are
very consistent in their
book, they basically explicitly
state this
pessimistic position.
They say, God knows how
to fix countries,
let's not even bother.
Mostly that's their the
position, and that's a very
internally consistent
position.
Now there are other people who
take a less consistent
position, who want
to say that the
institution is an important.
This is the evidence from
Acemoglu and Robinson, and now
we're going to go fix countries,
which is a very
different plan, that we're going
to fix institutions,
evidence doesn't say that you
can fix institutions.
It says if you had the right
institutions 400 years ago,
then it would be good.
That's very different from
saying we can fix
institutions.
You see that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
appropriate it would be with
history, time changes going on
in the world, but can you kind
of take this as if we could
transition towards better
institutions in some
countries, then maybe in 400
years those, countries would
be better
PROFESSOR: Maybe, but
not tomorrow.
So I have nothing useful to say
about 400 years from now,
but if we can.
But what it clearly doesn't say
is if a fixed institution
thing would be better today.
That's it does not say.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Africa, [INAUDIBLE]
nations [INAUDIBLE]
can't really have institutions
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's also true.
I think the point that you're
making is also important, and
we don't know how to [INAUDIBLE]
institutions.
It's not that people don't
live in [INAUDIBLE].
So here's a fact that I know
isn't in [INAUDIBLE].
Whoever owns any country,
take a taxi--
I'm talking about in
many countries.
Get off from the taxi.
You either agreed an amount when
you got on the taxi, or
there's a meter.
You read the meter, you give
the person the amount.
And at that point, the person
takes the money.
He shuts the meter off, and he
says, here's your change.
This happens in many,
many countries.
Now what's remarkable
about that?
What's remarkable is
why did I pay him?
I could have said no.
So what if it says $20?
I'm going to give you $5.
What's to stop me?
There's nobody else
was that's there.
Usually when I get off in front
of a house, there's no
one else there.
I can walk off.
By the time the taxi
driver can find the
policeman, I'll be gone--
on one side.
So the response has to be that
I'm afraid of the taxi driver
beating me up, which
may be true.
But if the taxi driver can
beat me up, why isn't the
reverse true?
As soon as the taxi stopped, why
isn't he trying to beat me
up, and saying you have to give
me $40 instead of $20, or
I'll beat you up, and claim
that you owe me $40.
How is it that we manage to
negotiate this space in many,
many countries successfully?
If I'm paying the taxi driver
who's a taxi driver who beat
me up, then he should beat
me up in any case.
And otherwise, if he can't beat
me up, then I shouldn't
pay him in any case.
So why do I pay him?
And why do these
transactions--
thousands of millions of
these transactions--
always happens?
So it must be that
even societies
that don't have good property
rights distribution enforced
up top have figured out ways to
enforce lots of contracts
on the ground.
That has to be true.
That a lot of what we call
property rights must live in
other forms than the form
that we think of as
the official form.
Yeah, you had a comment?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
if there's no policeman standing
there, you sort of
assume [INAUDIBLE]
there's a certain trust that
you have [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
Trust, or something like
that is important.
The only point I'm making
here, that's
not a property right.
That's something else
that is important.
So there's lots of substitutes.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
in terms of game theory, if you
play this game just one
time, of course you can say
that, oh, either way
you can have it.
But if you think of it as
playing a game over and over,
you could sustain--
PROFESSOR: Well, I don't
want to play with
the same taxi driver.
Next time, I'm going to cheat
the next taxi driver.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
for every taxi driver to beat
you up that one time, then all
the taxi drivers are going to
start beating people up, and
people will stop using taxis.
PROFESSOR: That's a bad outcome,
but that is the
outcome predicted by the game,
that there will be no taxis.
In fact, taxis exist because we
have trust, we have norms.
We have all kinds of things
which live outside this
institution frame.
So one point that I think is
important is to think of, if
you want to transplant
institutions, you have to
realize that institutions
already
exist in these countries.
Even the ones which you think
don't have institutions have
tons and tons of them.
And you're always trying to turn
existing institutions to
other institutions.
You're not creating issues in
a void ever, anywhere, ever.
So we'll pick that
up next time.